Thanksgiving is coming up oh this is one
of my favorite holidays if I had to get
my top five favorite sides five would
probably be my stuffing you got to put
stuffing SLG gravy yes there we go I'm
all about the combination I love my food
Touch number four I like turkey with the
yam juice right number three for me ooh
the cream corn when you have a delicious
cream corn oh man oh man number two
collard greens and hot sauce if you
don't got collard greens in your plate
like true
ghetto out the South Uptown Vibe collard
greens with red hot oh I I can't even
come to your Thanksgiving like come on
number one this is what gets the hu mac
and cheese with the Gams and you got to
put it together for the combination if
your Mac and yams on together I question
you this is what a real plate looks like
I'm going to be like 260 next week argue
with your mama that's the top five
period